C.I.A. LAST ADMINISTRATION.
MIKE POMPEO KNEW THIS.
HE REFUSED TO COME.
WE HOPE YOU WILL RECONSIDER.
IN THE MEANTIME, HAPPY TO BE
JOINED BY MIRANDA DIVINE.
THANK YOU FOR COMING UP.
I DON'T THINK WE HAVE PAUSED
LONG ENOUGH TO CONSIDER WHAT
THIS MEANS AFTER 60 YEARS, WE
CAN'T SEE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
ABOUT MAYBE THE PIVOTAL EVENT IN
MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY NOW WE
KNOW WHY.
>> TUCKER, YOU HAVE LAID IT OUT
REALLY WELL.
USED TO BE CONSERVATIVES LIKE ME
DISMISSED THEORIES FROM THE LEFT
ABOUT JFK'S ASSASSINATION ADDS
LEFT-WING CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
LEFT LOOKS AS THEY WERE QUITE
JUSTIFIED TRUSTING INTELLIGENCE
SERVICES.
IRAQ WAR WAS RED PILL FOR ME.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK ON A REALLY
BASIC LEVEL, YOU LOOK AT THE
FACT THAT 30 YEARS AGO, CONGRESS
IN A UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
UNEQUIVOCAL, UNAMBIGUOUS
DECISION SAID ALL JFK FILES HAVE
TO BE MADE PUBLIC.
ALMOST 60 YEARS AGO.
EVERYBODY INVOLVED DEAD.
YOU ARE NOT WORRIED ABOUT
UNMASKING A SPY OVERSEAS.
NO.
THEY CAN ONLY TWO REASONS:  ONE,
YOU ARE TRYING TO PROTECT THE
C.I.A. AGAINST UM, ALLEGATIONS
OR REVELATIONS THAT IT KNEW MORE
THAN IT MADE OUT ABOUT LEE
HARVEY OSWALD.
HUGE FILE.
IN CONTACT WITH HIM BEFORE
DANGER ASSASSINATION.
DIDN'T DO ENOUGH TO PROTECT THE
PRESIDENT.
IS THAT ENOUGH TO KEEP THIS
SECRET GOING FOR 60 YEARS?
TERRIBLE DAWNING RECOGNITION IS
THAT THIS IS ABOUT AS YOU SAID
PROTECTING THE INSTITUTION.
IF THE C.I.A. WAS INVOLVED IN
THAT ASSASSINATION, THAT IS THE
REASON YOU WOULD WANT TO KEEP
THAT FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BECAUSE THE FURRY THAT WOULD
ERUPT AND THIS IS A BIPARTISAN
FURY, THE ONE THING THAT WOULD
UNITE AMERICANS IS ABSOLUTE RAGE
AT THIS UNACCOUNTABLE SPY AGENCY
THAT IS -- HAS DECIDED IT IS
GOING TO GET INVOLVED IN
MURDERING, ASSASSINATING THE
DUALLY ELECTED AMERICAN
PRESIDENT FOR WHAT REASON?
UM, THERE WOULD BE SUCH A CLEAN
OUT OF THE C.I.A.
TRUST IN OUR INSTITUTIONS IS
ALREADY AT ROCK BOTTOM.
I THINK IT IS A MISTAKE FOR MIKE
POMPEO NOT TO COME ON YOUR SHOW.
ALL THIS DOES IS FUEL MORE
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
TRUTH IS THE BEST DISINFECTANT.
IF THE C.I.A. WAS INVOLVED 60
YEARS AGO, NEEDS TO COME CLEAN.
WE NEED TO HAVE A RECKONING.
>> THAT WAS ASSESSMENT DIRECTLY
FAMILIAR WITH THE CONTENTS OF
THESE DOCUMENTS.
NOT SOMEONE THAT READ IT ON THE
INTERNET.
SOMEONE WITH ACCESS TO THE
DOCUMENTS.
I AGREE WITH YOU SECRECY ABETS
EVIL.
WE SHOULD MINIMIZE AMOUNT OF
SECRECY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW JOHN
BRENNAN CAN GO ON NBC NEWS, WHAT
IS THIS, 60 YEARS, WHAT IS THE
REAL REASON?
WHY DOES NO ONE ASK HIM THAT?
>> MORE WE SEE CHARACTERS FROM
THE C.I.A. LIKE JOHN BRENNAN,
LIKE THE 51 INTELLIGENT
OFFICIALS THAT SIGNED THE LETTER
ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN BEING RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
NEEDS PEOPLE ARE IN THE SHADOWS
FOR A REASON.
IF YOU ACTUALLY SAW WHO THEY
WERE -- LOOK AT JOHN BRENNAN,
KNOWING WHAT WE KNOW WOULD YOU
INTRUST HIM TO RUN THE COUNTRY'S
SPY AGENCY?
TO HAVE SUCH POWER TO RUN AROUND
THE WORLD INTERVENING IN OTHER
COUNTRY'S ELECTIONS?
NO.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT GOOD IT DOES
HAVING THOSE PEOPLE HAVING SO
MUCH POWER AND CAUSING US GREAT
HARM.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.